myron one of the hosts was saying
it is cheating if a girl has an
instagram when she's in a relationship
um
but don't worry the men the men can have
an instagram though that's not cheating
and okay so the reason being is because
when you have social media on some level
you're looking for attention right
on some level you're looking for
attention from someone otherwise you
wouldn't post yes
no i agree
i have to agree with that no i i think
you
i love taking pictures
i do i love being creative but at the
end of the day if you have a crush on
someone
you post that one story for them to view
it oh we've all done that yeah you dress
up cute you do a little
we can't we can't yeah we don't
well you post that one like pretty
picture for him to be like
well my ex doesn't have he does i have
instagram though but i blocked him for
example and i do love to take pictures
but i don't do in order to i don't know
trigger him or tease him yeah or like to
get attention i do love photos i do love
myself i actually this probably sounds
a little bit
ego or
narcissists oh exactly i spend way more
time looking at my pictures than are
actually other people
i actually i'm like i don't give a [ __ ]
who pays attention to me yeah i actually
just like but then what the more i like
to see my profile like looking good you
know and that's it then but then why
post it at all and you can just keep
them in your camera roll yeah exactly
but i just like feel
a bit more like i can show to my friends
for example my instagram is pro it's
private yeah so i only accept people
that i want to they i mean to be you
know be there yeah see right i want to
share even though it's just people i met
once i feel okay it's a good vibe it's a
you know i will keep it but it's not in
order to get attention i feel like
i like it but it's literally for
attention because you're getting
attention it's getting attention from
people you know it might be a smaller
group yeah it can be it can be a very
like you said a small amount of group
but at the end of the day if it was just
for your eyes only yeah
you got it yeah yeah i think that's what
she's trying to say about like likes you
know no that's something else though
followers
it's just it's just there's levels to it
yeah it's a different level of attention
yeah yeah that's right yes
so the question i have for you guys um
is
do you think having an instagram is
cheating to start no no no no it gives
you the opportunity to okay
but everything gives you the opportunity
to cheat walking taking the tube gives
you an opportunity to cheat
not really not really
i feel like or not i don't feel like i
think i think instagram
has two has two
nowadays has like two main purposes
business or dating facts the reality is
so if if you're a girl
how many people have tried to slide in
your dms
how many of you guys have swiped up on a
story you know
i left the fire emoji or the heart or
something or like i mean just like
there's or it's either you're promoting
your business
or at some stage someone is going to
move to you or you're going to move to
someone else so i feel like
yeah instagram is one of one of those
two things so if it
offers you the opportunity to it's kind
it's kind of like you're selling
yourself like it's like your online
portfolio like your representation of
yourself like so you're sharing your
good parts like you're showing yourself
looking your best for other people
that's basically it though yeah no for
for attention for other people to view
it
so no but we were talking about the
other day
where like instagram and everything like
it's actually a social currency now like
even when you go out and stuff
the more followers you have the more
like you can do the easier to get into
things
yeah 100 it's that element of it the
business element but as a girl if your
instagram is open and it's not private
like you want the attention if you're
not doing if you're not if you're not
trying to like sell site towards a
business or like do something i feel
like it's for attention
a little bit i think it's a great way to
have an instagram even if it's open or
private i mean when it's open of course
i think you have way more
possibilities you know to create a
business to share and to create more
following definitely
uh some i i don't think is like the main
reason is like to like to create an
instagram is to she i'm sorry to cheat
no [ __ ]
uh but
i mean
um i think you can [ __ ] [ __ ]
in portuguese guys don't judge me um
[ __ ] cheat cheat thank you
cheat uh you can cheat anywhere you know
i mean there was cheating before
instagram before social media before
internet i i think even my parents i
don't know if they cheat but you know
even that happened before but without
internet without you know uh smartphones
it was like a nokia the snake game you
know that's it
but i think what he was trying to say i
i agree with you that's what i said as
well but i think it gives you an outlet
to do it easier yeah we have
i think all of us have experienced
someone being a relationship posting it
and then they swipe up on your story
yeah you're like
what
well i think it just gives you that
interesting stat
one and three affairs that cause a
divorce are from social media exactly
yeah yeah one and three
there we go so i feel like social media
has made it harder for relationships to
work because you're as you're as a guy
you're seeing all these beautiful girls
on your timeline
constantly you're gonna be tempting
you're like oh there's more beautiful
girls out there you're good seeing all
these girls so you're so it's like it's
tempting you and you're seeing that
every day constantly constantly you're
like oh
oh yeah i think it works both ways as
well though because as a guy
like back in the day you were just
obviously before social media if you
were just competing with the guys that
went to your school or the guys in your
area and now you're competing with
people from america that have yachts
people who have
planes
like and you're just here like
i'm making off but like oh i ain't got
new york do you know what no you go you
go first the amount of girls i know so
like that aren't that aren't the
the greatest looking in the world like
just normal yeah that have mud
is it because she
while she looks average in real life on
her instagram it's so edited she looks
above average
yeah instagrams are like not like so
edited just she reveals
she she's like a good body catfish
catfish no she's a decent body but she's
not wearing a lot yeah yeah so it's kind
of screaming like easy
i don't know what you're talking about
there's a thin line as well between that
subject i think some people they feel
like they think like some women they
show too much it's because they want
they are weak and they are insecure and
they are trying to
you know
call some attention
but i don't think so like some people
maybe some other people not i think it's
all about who you are in the end of the
day because sometimes i met a few people
they look so wow on instagram and then
you meet them and they are very humble
they are very confident like confident
you know and they are not at all what
you think yeah but i
i think that
if you're posting your body on instagram
it's a hundred percent for attention
like there is nothing else that it is
for yep you want you want validation for
your body i'm not
i'm not above it
i understand where you're coming from
and half of it is 100 thought right i
think also when you're like um happy
with something or proud of it like proud
of the work have you done like the
progress you made yeah you do but
absolutely for people to see it or else
it would have been staying in your
camera i agree yeah but i think also to
show that you're like proud of it yeah
so
so other question when
on social media
what do you guys consider cheating i'm
going to give you a couple examples
this is fun so guys liking instagram
models bikini pictures
i mean that's not cheating no it's it's
it's not cheating but it's like why was
that necessary
but if you it's not cheating oh yeah
like why are you cheating but it's just
kind of moist
why are you doing it bro but if you saw
like a male
would you no because i was like why
would i do it but i understand cheating
you think um
i didn't it's like it's okay for the
guys out there that do that like why
yeah exactly
she doesn't see exactly yeah on the
guy's part it's just thirsty and it's a
bit moist yeah
it's a bit moist like you shouldn't yeah
there's no point in doing that just look
let's go that's it yeah yeah i think we
all have eyes and we appreciate
beautiful things it's human so if i see
a guy that is pretty and he looks good
and he looks hot even on the street i
mean i'm not going to be like like on
him but
if i see on instagram why not you know
like even if you're in relationship yeah
i feel like at least i can see if my
partner is confident and if you trust me
okay my partner doesn't trust me and my
partner is insecure and i'm i'm not up
to that
you know i think everyone has
insecurities but you should not um i how
do you say miro
those insecurities were mothers wait
who'd you say that again so what makes
them insecure
like me liking someone who's
not liking how would you say me thinking
that someone is beautiful it's okay to
see right she's beautiful right he's
beautiful yeah but that's something else
though that's something completely else
that's just appreciating that people are
like yeah but i think there's a
difference between looking at someone
and interacting with it i think that's
sending them a message exactly
it's the message you're sending no no
but i like like i think
it's it's like baby steps you know what
i mean like it starts it starts
for him to like because most of the time
nowadays i feel like especially girls on
instagram their way of shooting their
shot is they just like one or two of
your photos boys as well men as well
some guys will follow the girl if you're
like if you're like if you're about that
life you just lack a few and just see
what happens in it but here's the thing
because usually nine times out of ten
the man is pursuing
the like
if if a guy likes a girl's photo
she's
most of the time she's not gonna then
jump in his dm's most of the time he
might like it back and wait for him to
do it if the girl likes a guy's picture
that's that's an invitation that's yeah
that's a golden ticket slide in please
yeah yeah so
yeah
so the guys so girls yeah they'll like
two or three photos and that's when you
know that's when you slide in yeah
that's when you know that's when you
know that's like this especially if
you've just post a photo and you they've
just liked it that's nothing but if you
haven't posted anything in a couple
weeks they've gone on your page they've
gone through your photos
like it might not even be the most
recent free it might be they've scrolled
through liked a couple photos what if
what if they because that's the new
thing like liking instagram stories do
you guys think that's also an invitation
just like instagram stories
if you like instagram
[Music]
do you know a good thing about that as
well no one can see the light because
that's a good
because sometimes you might click on you
might click on a photo you might look
through the likes see who are who's
liked it as one of my boys liked it but
stories you can't do that so so
yeah
so
so what okay so what about swiping up on
someone's story yeah is that cheating is
that okay okay
is that cheating but you know the person
if you know the point but as in as in
does he swipe up and he's like oh have a
good workout or is it okay let's say
let's say you you have um an
acquaintance that both of both of you
know okay the guy you and the guy right
and he swipes up on our stories how do
you know if it like is it ever friendly
no is it always not dirty
it is flirty what about guys what do you
think
so can you we're gonna repeat that okay
so say say um
okay say me and you are dating right and
you and i'm your mutual oh yeah we're
the mutual friend
you always are swiping up on her story
but like we both draw the call right
is it ever friendly
if i'm always doing it there's there's
an under there's probably an underlying
exactly yeah
like i said if he's just like oh do you
know when or was the movie good was this
good like what that's that's fine
but like reacting
to the picture where she looks fire